This is Waladuna Mosque in Jakarta.
Itsroof is in ruins.
Moss covers the walls.
And sea water flows
through every corner of it.
The last time people prayed here wasin 2001,
back when it was above ground.
Today, it’s a warning sign.
It signals what could happen to Indonesia’s
capital city if things don’t change soon.
Because, even though Jakarta
faces the same sea rising levels
asother coastal cities around the world,
that’s not quite what we’re looking at here.
Jakarta is sinking.
And it’sbeen sinking for decades.
These blue areas show just how much
the city has sunk since the 1970s.
The darker the area gets, the more it's dropped.
Here's how much it's descended today.
Most of the sinking happens here,
in the northcoast,
where Jakarta meets the Java Sea.
Here, the land is sinking by about 25 cm a year,
destabilizing the area,
damaging homes,
andupending people’s lives,
over and over again.
Many residents here are fishermen, who need
to live by the coast to make a living,
but, further inland, Jakarta’s more than
10 million residents are also at risk.
A huge portion of the city, and thehomes of
millions, could be underwaterby 2050.
Jakarta sits on a
swampy plain, on low coastal land.
It has 13 rivers that drain through it.
But the reason the city is sinking
is actuallythat most people here
don’t have enough water.
Most Jakartans lack access
to clean, piped water.
Instead, they get their water
by digging wells like this one.
The pumps go deep into the ground to
extract the water stored in aquifers,
underground layers of rock
that hold groundwater.
The porous spaces of the rock
are filled with it.
Multiply this by a few million,
and you have a problem.
Think of the rock as a soakedsponge:
the more water is extracted,
the more it deflates,
causing the soil to compactand collapse,
and the ground above it to sink.
Pumps alone shouldn’t be able to do this.
While some layers of earth
will never recover their water,
aquifersare usually
refilled naturally when it rains.
But in Jakarta, that’s
becoming increasingly rare.
For decades, Jakarta has been
developing ata fast pace,
and is now covered in concrete.
So the rainfall that would usually fillup
the aquifers isn’t being absorbed.
It’s gotten so bad that in
coastal areas prone to flooding,
like the fishing community Muara Baru,
people have built makeshift bridges
to move through their neighborhoods.
Combined with sea level rise,
it's also made floods during high tide
and rainy seasons much more dangerous.
Like in 2007, when Jakarta
experienced oneof the worst floods
in its modern history.
A storm and high tide caused rivers
and canalsaround the city to overflow,
killing 80 people.
Maksim has already lost
his home to the sinking,
and now sleeps on his fishing boat.
AndNondho has had to rebuild
his home several times.
Groundwater pumping is putting
Jakarta’s survival at risk.
But to understand how it got
into this situationto begin with,
you have to go back centuries.
In the 1600s, when European
powers were colonizing the world,
the Dutch took over what was then
the port town of Jayakarta.
They razed it to the ground,
and in its place, builtBatavia:
a headquarters for their growing empire.
They began to rule over the Indonesian,
Chinese, Indian, and Arab people
who had lived there for centuries,
and built their new city
in the Dutch style,
with narrow townhouses
along a grid of canals.
The canals were used for trade, defense,
and to make Batavia feel like a Dutch city.
But look at Batavia from above,
and you cansee the city grid
served a darker purpose, too.
If you look closely, you'll notice
that there aren’t many bridges
between the two sides,
or between theblocks.
This was by design.
The Dutch were outnumbered.
So, in order tocontrol the local
population, they divided it.
It looked like this.
Pretty much everygroup was
confined to their city quarter.
The Dutch ruled over the local
population likethis for over a century.
But thatbegan to change
in the mid-1700s.
Because the Dutch didn’t properly maintain
the canals, they began to deteriorate,
and sediment from earthquakes
blocked the flow of water.
The water in the canals turned
stagnant, and soon, deadly.
As disease spread through the canals,
thewealthier Dutch moved
south of Batavia,
where they began to develop a new
colonial administrative center.
But, despite the death and disease, theDutch
continued to leave the canalsuntreated.
Instead, they began to use piped water.
In the 1870s, they developed the
first centralized water supply,
with iron pipes to
distribute water to homes.
The pipes provided clean drinking
water and indoor bathrooms.
But the pipes were concentrated in these
areas, where the Dutch had moved to.
The indigenous population was left in
informal settlements, called "kampongs,"
far from the piped water.
And this createda new
kind of division in the city.
Native residents had to rely
on street vendors for water.
But most often, they were forced to get
their water from the neglected canals.
It took decades before pipes were
finally built in these communities.
And when they were, it would
only be a few public standpipes.
This continued through 1949.
After an armed conflict, the Dutch finally
recognizedIndonesia’s independence, and left.
The legacy they left behind
was a sprawling city,
built on marshland,
and segregated by wateraccess,
that, now, Jakartans had to deal with.
Over the next decades,
Jakarta’s population skyrocketed.
More people required more housing,
more stores,and more streets.
And the city expanded fast.
But its water infrastructure still
doesn’t serve the majority of the city.
This chart shows how much of
Jakarta’s population has piped water.
It was 12 percent in the 50s, and
is still under 50 percent today.
Many of the people without
access to pipedwater
have no other choice but to keep
pumping groundwaterto survive.
And the city continues to sink.
The situation has gotten so bad,
the Indonesian government has talked
about moving the capital, from Jakarta,
to the neighboring island of Borneo.
But that won’t help the millions
of people living in Jakarta.
To save the city, in 2014, the
government announced a project,
in collaboration with a
Dutch architecture firm,
to build and reinforce
120 km of seawalls,
to stop the water from flooding
the land as it sinks.
But so far, only these 10 kilometers
have beenreinforced.
Like this one in Muara Baru.
The problem is that, just like the rest
of Jakarta, the seawall is sinking.
The project also includes an
ambitious$40 billion plan
to build a 38 km wall,
shaped like a massive bird,
to protect the coast from flooding.
But this project could take
up to 30 years to complete.
And by then, Jakarta could have
lost most of its coastal land.
Jakarta will continues to sink until
groundwater stops being pumped.
And groundwater will
continue to be pumped
until the government
provides an alternative.
This has been done before.
In the 1950s,
Tokyo managed to stop severe
sinking by providing piped water.
Taipei, Shanghai, Bangkok,
are other cities in the region
that have managed to
stop their citiesfrom sinking.
But time is running out.
Jakarta has been free of Dutch rule
fora little over 70 years now.
But the way the Dutch
built their city, carved it up,
andrestricted its water,
plagues it to this day.
Jakarta is sinking into the sea.
And, until itsgovernment figures out how
to provide clean, piped water for its citizens,
that will continue tobe its reality.
For as long as it’s still here.